[Musica]
produrre cibo ha un impatto economico ed
ambientale molto molto forte è
necessario invertire la rotta è
necessario trovare altre soluzioni
sostenibili è necessario come piace dire
a noi fare una rivoluzione agricola
io sono daniela chiapperini è insieme a
raffaele settanni abbiamo fondato una
startup pugliese e ci occupiamo di
produrre spirulina una microalga per
nutrire in modo sostenibile
nello specifico ci occupiamo di ricerca
nell'ambito delle microalghe produzione
di spirulina quindi pura naturale al 100
per cento e made in italy in
collaborazione con altre realtà del
nostro territorio realizziamo prodotti a
base di spirulina quindi prodotti
funzionali arricchiti di spirulina e
portiamo avanti delle attività di
ricerca nell'ambito della dei campi
d'applicazione della spirulina e delle
microalghe in generale il nostro
progetto imprenditoriale nasce da alcune
domande che poi sono diventate le nostre
sfide ed alcuni bisogni diciamo del
nostro territorio
una delle domande quale cibo nei nostri
piatti sempre più la nostra
alimentazione ma ancor di più lo stile
di vita che conduciamo ogni giorno non è
adeguato per la nostra nutrizione è
sviluppiamo delle problematiche legate
alle cattive abitudini alimentari come
ad esempio l'obesità il colesterolo il
diabete e carenze alimentari o
vitaminiche l'altra domanda è come
nutrire in modo sostenibile un mondo
sempre più popolato come ben sapete la
popolazione sta aumentando e quindi è
necessario trovare delle alternative
sostenibili per poter nutrire però tutto
il pianeta
quando pensiamo alle fonti di
inquinamento solitamente ci viene in
mente l'industria chimica ci viene in
mente
i trasporti ci vengono in mente ma in
realtà quello che inquina maggiormente è
l'agricoltura e gli allevamenti
intensivi dietro tutto il cibo che noi
mangiamo per produrlo ci sono tutte le
risorse che noi consumiamo e ogni anno
consumiamo una terra e mezza per
produrre cibo
pensate che per produrre un chilo di
carne noi consumiamo 15.500 litri di
acqua e in cambio in atmosfera e
mettiamo più di 6 kg di co2
ecco perché è necessario trovare delle
alternative è la spirulina è una di
queste alternative
la fao nel 2007 e l'ha definita il cibo
del futuro
proprio per le sue proprietà nutritive
ma anche per la sua sostenibilità
ambientale la spirulina è un prodigio
della natura è l'alimento più completo e
nutriente che si trova in natura è
l'alimento vegetale con il più alto
contenuto di proteine arrivano fino a
tre volte quelle della carne e completa
dal punto di vista delle vitamine e
completa dal punto di vista dei sali
minerali contiene 45 volte il ferro
degli spinaci omega 3 e omega 6
antiossidanti è un cibo completo e per
questo è stata definita un super food ma
dal punto di vista ambientale e molto
molto interessante perché coltivarla a
dei bassissimi costi ambientali non
possiamo utilizzare ad esempio possiamo
coltivare la spirulina su terreni non
fertili quindi senza togliere terreno
alle produzioni di cibo non utilizziamo
pesticidi non c'è bisogno di utilizzare
veleni e pensate per ottenere le stesse
proteine della carne utilizziamo
soltanto un cinquantesimo dell'acqua
quindi con un risparmio idrico molto
molto interessante è ancor più
interessante per ogni chilo di spirulina
secca prodotta che poi dopo potrete
anche assaggiare fuori dall'atmosfera
fissiamo ben 2 kg di co2
quindi siamo in controtendenza
senza rispetto alle come dire
coltivazioni tradizionali agli
allevamenti intensivi
ecco perché potrebbe rappresentare una
delle soluzioni
noi siamo un team di giovani giovani
pugliesi con delle competenze delle
esperienze molto diversificate tra di
noi ma quello che ci accomuna è che
tutti quanti noi vogliamo contribuire a
questa rivoluzione agricola allora in
realtà la nostra storia inizia alcuni
anni fa
una storia molto bella perché nasce in
un paese molto bello
nasce in terra africana in malawi perché
io appunto mi sono occupata di progetti
di cooperazione allo sviluppo ed ero lì
per questi progetti
accanto ad un centro nutrizionale con
raffaele che era lì per collaborare per
questo progetto abbiamo conosciuto per
la prima volta la spirulina l'aspirina
veniva coltivata per integrare la dieta
dei bambini malnutriti di questo centro
nutrizionale di questo paese poverissimo
del malawi e veniva anche data pensate
per rafforzare il sistema immunitario
dei malati di aids
lì la nostra vita è cambiata perché
quando siamo arrivati in puglia grazie
al bando della regione puglia principi
attivi nel 2012 abbiamo voluto provare
ad invertire le logiche di sviluppo che
solitamente ci vedono esportare dei
modelli di conoscenza dei modelli
economici
abbiamo voluto invertire queste logiche
di sviluppo abbiamo creato il primo
impianto pilota in puglia abbiamo messo
a punto un processo un prodotto di
altissima qualità
e così è iniziata la nostra storia da
allora abbiamo mosso
molti passi tra cui uno molto importante
è quello che ci ha visto vincitori poi
al bando valore assoluto 3.0 della
camera di commercio di bari che ci ha
dato la possibilità di trasformare
quello che era un impianto pilota in un
impianto vero e proprio diciamo di
produzione di microalghe di ricerca
quindi la start up e la
la società che oggi esiste la nostra
indagine di mercato quando abbiamo
iniziato dalla nostra indagine di
mercato è emerso che la spirulina
prodotta in italia è consumata in italia
in realtà non veniva prodotta in italia
ma per il 97 per cento era di
provenienza extra europea
quindi si perdeva la tracciabilità e
soprattutto non era un prodotto puro
perché la troviamo e diciamo in
compresse in pasticche in tablet quindi
noi abbiamo voluto creare questo stick
per differenziare la spirulina italiana
da una spirulina extra europea per
veicolare il senso che la spirulina è un
cibo è un super cibo è un cibo con delle
proprietà nutri tra celtica ma è un cibo
e quindi oggi noi produciamo spirulina
pura al 100 per 100 naturale made in
italy biologica ma soprattutto
sostenibile in collaborazione con altre
realtà del mondo delle imprese della
ricerca eccetera
portiamo avanti delle attività di
ricerca nell'ambito dei vari campi
d'applicazione dalla dalle alghe dalla
spirulina dalle microalghe in generale
si possono fare si può lavorare non solo
nel cibo nei super food ma si può
lavorare anche nell'ambito della
cosmetica
immaginate dalle dalle alghe si possono
fare biofertilizzanti dalle alghe si può
si può fare bioplastica e qualcuno ha
già fatto anche il biodiesel e ritorno
un po a quello che si diceva poc'anzi in
realtà abbiamo un mondo spaccato in due
dove la malnutrizione appartiene al
paese ai paesi ricchi
così come ai paesi poveri ci sono
persone nel nel mondo dei paesi poveri
che non hanno accesso al cibo e non
hanno accesso nemmeno alla produzione di
cibo e dall'altro lato ci sono persone
che producono tantissimo cibo che
consumano risorse per produrre quel cibo
che poi non mangiano tutto perché viene
sprecato e quindi inquinano due volte
con la conseguenza che nel mondo nell
atmosfera vengano emesse all'anno 3,3
miliardi di tonnellate di co2
ecco perché è necessario invertire la
tendenza e nutrire il pianeta in modo
sostenibile è possibile è possibile ad
esempio mangiando quindi scegliendo di
mangiare o scegliendo di produrre in
questo modo la spirulina se dovessi
pensare alle abitudini del del futuro
sicuramente non posso fare a meno di
pensare alla stretta interdipendenza tra
noi e l'ambiente e domani quando
penseremo a cosa vogliamo mangiare a
pranzo
ricordiamoci che siamo strettamente
legati l'uno all'altro siamo
strettamente legati al nostro territorio
e siamo strettamente legati all'ambiente
grazie
[Musica]